that I inherit from it because even
though she might not go tick for attack
for him she might not go but there
she'll have an attitude for a few days
and it's justifiable for her attitude
and the silent treatment and things like
that and I was like I never want to
treat my husband that way right and so
over that was in my younger days but as
we've evolved and she's matured she's
come out of that a little bit more and
it's it's not a thing but inadvertently
when I was growing up I was exposed to
that right and even um my mom was she
worked and so a lot of um the things
that I had to learn I was in an
environment with men right I had a
stepfather two two older stepbrothers
and a younger brother and that's the
environment that I was in with a mom who
worked do you feel like your mom failed
to teach you femininity absolutely and
we've I've had that conversation with
her absolutely was it do you feel like
it would have been better if she was at
home with you
not other than working not necessarily
and I'm gonna tell you why because my
mom and her side of the family they come
from a place of very private very keep
keep even if she was home she wouldn't
have taught me because if for them it
was a sense of Pride and it's something
we don't talk about why didn't why
didn't she learn femininity from like
her mom but I think she did oh she did
but she did in that generation how they
learned it and so it's not that she
didn't teach me anything absolutely she
taught me stuff but the things that I
had to just kind of through osmosis not
really but in college when I got around
my friends and when I when I observed
them they were they took my level of
feminine energy and hygiene to another
level because I had good friends in a
circle but the responsibility shouldn't
have lied on them and it didn't and then
I got to a certain age and it's like
well I want to get even better about
this but these are honestly they're hard
conversations to have when you have you
don't feel a level of vulnerability and
comfort that for whatever reason I don't
believe my mom felt who um I'm curious
who on the panel feels like their mom
taught them to be a proper wife
Auntie Jenny
really wow
this is crazy I was um raised by my
great-grandmother but I felt like she
taught me the proper way and just
unfortunately didn't work for me and
guys this is just a random group of
women this isn't like cherry-picked this
is you guys had recruiters reach out to
you it's copy and paste Instagram people
with open profiles
um usually and I will say my grandmother
my grandmother influences Unfortunately
they died when I was young but they it
was an influence from them but if it's
not cultivated throughout life if it's
only for a certain stint it's the
seedest planet but we need somebody else
to come along and cultivate that then to
grow that so it's in there but I had to
go in and later in life when I realized
it wasn't cultivated properly go back
and re-stimulate that and cultivate it
yeah and I'm not saying you can't learn
it later but it's just like you're
starting it's like you're competing with
women that were raised to be wives so
they've been learning to be a wife from
10 years old and you you said you
started at like 27 28 so having to
relearn right so even even if you
learned you know
five years it's like I'm compared
it's an honest question when I'm dating
now and people are like well you're 33
you're single you're accomplished
whatever whatever you're beautiful why
aren't you married it is a very good
question do you feel that you've become
the man you wanted to marry so man so
what I mean maybe no no so so I'm saying
like in terms of your accomplishments
like you'd want a guy with your similar
accomplishments like you're in shape
you'd want a guy in shape like you like
would you say a lot of your
accomplishments like have maybe become
the man you wanted to marry
no I wouldn't say because I don't
necessarily want to marry a man who's
established in that way I'll marry
somebody who's just literally a driver
right that isn't you wouldn't prefer it
you wouldn't prefer someone and I'm I'm
gonna be really honest right now and say
not necessarily because what I find is
those type of men the character isn't
always there right because they are
looking for the 20 years being equal so
everything being equal driver lawyer
you wouldn't pick the lawyer I don't
wanna yeah I would never marry another
lawyer the debates in the conversation
I I find it so interesting that um women
are not demonized for raising women but
men are demonized for not raising men
it's it's so it's so interesting to me
and it just goes back to you know the
privilege of being a woman and that
we're I'm judged by different standards
that's so true because whenever there's
a [__] kid or they'll always say oh he
had a deadbeat dad but they never really
talk about the women I mean that in a
way had dead Beats beat moms because
they weren't presents it has to be
extreme like she has to be strung out
and yeah I'm sorry I didn't want to
interrupt but I
[Music]
I wasn't raised to be a housewife or to
be a wife at all was your mom in the
picture yeah so my mom and dad are still
we each other
dude was it was did she work or like my
mom and dad they both worked so like my
nanny and Granddad would look after me
when I was younger well I would still
see how my mom would treat my dad and
what she would do for my dad you know I
just took that into account of how I
treat Amanda I'm just curious how did
you like growing up with a nanny did you
so it was my own it was my grandmother
it was my own grandmother sorry for me
so you know I was still getting the same
you know what I mean so I can only like
I said I can only speak for myself in
this I wasn't taught right you do this
for a man or you do that for man but I
seen what was done for a man and I took
that into account okay so this is how
I'll treat my husband I'll cook for my
husband but if he wants to put something
into the house he'd want something to
the house if he's if he's the main
Breadwinner if not if he's demanded
house you know did you did you grow up
like fixing your data plate ever did
they ever teach you that sort of stuff
and kind of I got taught like if you're
making dinner for yourself you're making
dinner for everybody no matter who is
around you you know what I mean that's
what I was kind of so where did you feel
like you were lacking
like what what do you feel like wasn't
there
I feel like I wasn't taught properly how
you notice hole when you're younger men
will like pick on you and like oh if
he's picking on you it means he likes
you this is I see that as now as well I
wasn't taught that like when you're
older men still might not be like you
you're amazing you're a princess like
the Disney World so do you feel like you
are more allowed to by the media or by
your family probably by the media rather
than my family yeah in my opinion
definitely and they they sold you a
dream sort of oh one million do you guys
do you guys who of you feels like you
were
sold trying to write away the phrase
this question who
who feels like
they were sold at Prince Charming that
was never going to come like there was
some perfect guy and it's okay if you
don't I'm just wondering you do I'm
still waiting for him I think it was a
harsh reality because my mum and dad
have been together like just I'm just
curious just one no me this one no you
didn't feel like that you didn't feel
like okay cool go ahead so my mom and
dad have been together like from like
really young they've been together ever
since they're not married but they've
been together like a long time so I
always just thought that's what happens
like so when I met my first boyfriend it
didn't work out it was like oh okay like
I am a relationship person I love love
like I just wanted it to be like that so
whenever I met someone and it failed it
was always like a oh you know so it
wasn't that I don't think anyone failed
me but
it was like a full sense of like oh like
you know what I mean you do say are you
in a relationship now no no okay
um and you say you're you're a
relationship person do you feel like you
present yourself like one
um
I wouldn't say I'm really looking for
that now probably that's why it maybe
comes across like that no I'm asking you
I didn't say you did or you didn't
um I'm not really looking so I wouldn't
say I present myself as someone that's
looking like do you do you want to look
in the future maybe I don't know I just
think when when you have so many I think
so many failed you know like you said
like your numbers go up and you know
like you I just don't I want I don't
want to keep
um hey in a brick wall like I'm just
like oh I'd rather just focus on being
happy focus on making money and yeah
have you ever thought about why you
failed in the in the past you know why
um
I think I
not to be deep but I think I'd go for
like broken men and I try to fix them
and I've just always done it do you
think you are what you attract
um
I don't think I don't think so maybe I
don't know I wouldn't say so no I just
I'm quite an EMP empath so I just like
to I like to care
yeah yeah and just be nice to just not
fix someone it'd be nice to meet someone
and them just be like you know just good
have you have you met guys that you
don't have to fix
um not in a relationship time probably
no never like not on the street not you
know
I mean like I said unless I don't know
I've just been in relationships to be
honest and then when I'm in a
relationship I'm not actively you know
so and then if I'm not in a relationship
I'm dealing with what happened and then
yeah so I don't I don't really if unless
I'm interacting on like a friendship
level
I'm tired of your side you thought you
were about to say something no no I was
just uh intently listening you know I
but I will quickly comment that um
I've been waiting my turn inside you
know what I'm saying um but I thought
that was a very interesting uh line of
questioning right because what Pro asks
is is that you know do you attract what
you are and what you only find to see is
to be broken right so you know I think
like you know we are the relationships
that we get into we're all reflections
of us
so you know my next question is is you
know have you done work within yourself
in therapy to understand kind of where
your deficiencies might be so you can
subtract better the way that I'm talking
about broken would be things that I
don't necessarily have come from so like
a broken home may be as affected a
person I don't come from that
um maybe substance abuse again I've not
had that around me so in in the
instances that I'm talking about and I
wouldn't say it does really reflect on
me maybe in other aspects that I've not
dived into but I don't think necessarily
no if the man of your dreams came around
right now do you think you would be
prepared for him I don't know I think I
have healing to do to be honest
you need to heal something that's broken
so you consider yourself broken
huh maybe maybe I don't know broken
feels quite harsh I know I used it to
describe them but on me I'm not ready
on a harsh intent it's just something
that I've I've stumbled on like I've
realized I didn't know at first because
people mask it and then the deeper
you're you're with someone you're like
oh
it's like if you're afraid to get in a
relationship now then wouldn't you say
something's broken
because you're hurt right yeah yeah yeah
because we're better together than we
are apart would you agree or disagree
if you're with the right person yeah you
don't gotta be a caveat on that you know
we're tribal people
really together is better than apart
that's the way that we're designed to be
the amount of mental health issues that
have sprung up since
the 19 started because now we are an
at-home culture and it's getting a lot
better right now up in front of our TV
screens whether it be social media or
what have you
um the rate of prescriptions depression
of medications are skyrocketing and
going through the roof and I think it a
lot of it has to do with the lack of
community in person in reality community
and relationships that we are building
the most important relationship that
you're going to build throughout your
life is going to be with a significant
other so if you were to find the Menace
broken but you're unwilling to Define
yourself as broken which already right
there that's there's an issue within
that as well yeah right I think we all
got to have a degree of reality within
ourselves right me you know I'm I wanted
a flat though but I feel like my some of
my Brokenness is from how I've been
treated rather than maybe like I think I
was just happy like I'm very like um
naive like I'm just I love you know I
just want to love non-broken wouldn't
allow themselves to be mistreated
sure sure so it all falls back on you
yeah true no one else but you
can I can I say I I just want to say
something in
um from a loving place and this is not
just for you this is just for still
being in the healing journey and process
as of myself but when you spoke about
the Brokenness in men and just in
general when we identify with people
it's a cause and it's an effect to
things you spoke to the effect of it
right oh they are um strung out
um they're homeless whatever the effect
of something may be that's just the
effect we have to go back to the root
cause of where that came from looking at
the the process and the different things
that happen to them and I think when we
do that we might find that we align with
them in more of a way that identifies
our own Brokenness and our own hurt and
shows that we both have similar healing
to do
um in that process and that's just the
way I think about people I always ask
myself why why did you do this why where
is this coming from in your life and it
started with me I had to say okay you
got Daddy Issues girl but where did this
come from and where have I seen the
cycle reappearing in my life and let's
go back to each and every one of them
and reframe it and fix exit and reframe
it until my thinking at a default is
reset and redone and that's the part of
the healing process and it still has to
happen over and over again because the
brain is so powerful our negative
thoughts they happen so quickly it we
have to in order to rewire a negative
thought we have to think something
positive a minimum of seven times and a
negative thought just takes that because
the impact of a negative thought the
emotional feeling of it is so powerful
that it takes us rewiring that with
positive thinking and shutting down the
negative thought over and over again and
then once you do that you have to
continue to do that and that's hard
because we are our own worst critics and
so when you are going through that
healing process it is work and it takes
time but you have to identify what the
root trigger is what is the root factor
of this that has caused me to go down
this the effect that I'm having the
Brokenness I get you I'm a lover I love
love and sometimes we can say that we
crave it and we want it so bad but if we
are compromising that and we are not
ending up with the relationships that we
want at some point you have to look and
identify itself I'm a good person I love
heart but what is broken inside of me
that I'm not getting that that I'm not
attracting that um go ahead I just
wanted to say that it seems like most
women
most single modern women with businesses
they concentrate more on the business
improving their business and improving
themselves because it sounds like all
the modern women out there with
businesses need therapy
they need some kind of help but rather
than concentrating them myself they're
concentrating on the business and then
they want to look for a man they might
not give a [__] about your business you
know what I mean so the energy that
you're putting into your business put
into yourself and then perhaps you'll
get a man and he might support you
having a business but right now all I
can hear is single women having business
they need therapy they're concentrating
their business is successful
but their brains [__] up mm-hmm
yeah they need to concentrate forget
about your business because the men care
more about you having a good mental
health than having a good business so
forget about your business and
concentrate on your own mental health
you know what's crazy about that sorry
go ahead yeah I was gonna say would you
just say this so it's so important and
honestly you know big upset of content
in the sector and I you know as because
it's not very humble to Big up yourself
but like a lot of modern women today
hate the content in the sector but this
content in the sector is what's going to
help them to understand how [__] up
their situations currently are it
creates the burning platform for them to
want more and do more just even you
and understanding that there might be a
degree of Brokenness within that you
wouldn't even quite come to that
conclusion unless you were sitting in
this particular platform right here to
understand the burning platform and
here's the thing once you begin to heal
that Brokenness you begin to understand
other thoughts feelings ideologies or
things that you believe then will begin
to change we had a whole conversation
about the sex work thing before I bet
you if you become into an unbroken State
one where you say that God that I'm
looking at right now I'm in a good
position to attract that guy once you
get there those feelings will change but
in a broken State what's all around the
Brokenness is ideas that you have that
have nothing to do with the togetherness
mindset try try you know I would say
when they say manifesting manifestation
try manifest actions yeah everybody sits
there and they want to Manifest this
idea man but nobody puts in the hard
work boom as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible